Leaving the temple, on our way to Skytree, we saw a rickshaw.
It's kind of cool because you get to see the modern cars passing behind it.
We're gonna challenge ourselves at Tokyo Skytree.
It is new and it's also the largest broadcasting tower built in 2008.
Here.
And here's our ticket.
After a smooth but heart-accelerating elevator ride, we arrived at the dock.
Can you believe this?
We are now officially 450 meters above the ground.
And we have to tell you that the city outside these windows is amazing.
Wow! Things are so tiny down there.
It is really amazing how a neighborhood around a traditional temple...
...could quickly transform into a bustling city.
Indeed, modernization is not an excuse to eradicate our heritage,...
...and we think that Japan has just proven that to the world.